welcome back to the rich eisen show uh
thrilled to have this guest on not only
because she's an all-time great at
uh competing but also as a human being
on the planet 20 wimbledon championships
39 grand slam titles uh a hero in my
household growing up and uh now an
author of all in an autobiography which
is available now wherever books are sold
billie jean king here on the rich eisen
show how are you billie jean
excellent how are you rich i am better
for talking to you so
my first question here is anytime i hear
an all-time great receive an honor that
i thought they'd already received like
say going in the hall of fame like wait
they're not in yet is this your first uh
auto autobiography have you not done
this before is this an update what what
where did this come from
well the last the last book was and i
didn't really get involved with a i was
not involved that when the last one
i was involved with with a little bit
was um kim chapin back in
1974. so i haven't really done a proper
book
um since 74 when i was in my 20s and i'm
78 this year so this is this is it man i
let it it took over four years to do it
uh got lots of help from a lot of people
and
had a full-time research person had
so many people involved trying to find
out the facts because as you know
truth is never the same in memory so it
was helpful with the researchers getting
newspaper clippings or videotapes or
things just to
remind me of getting the dates right
even you know it's amazing how your mind
plays little tricks on it so it it was a
labor of love i want to get it right
i think it's a great research book for
people that
need to do research on
me anyway i mean i still get a lot of
requests
from every age group but particularly
young people actually very young we're
talking like 10 to 15 to do interviews
and to do reports
and this book will be very helpful to
anybody who uh wants to do proper
research
what part i think that'll help well
because even in the book there's an
appendix with all my matches and scores
and all kinds of facts in there but i
really do
dig deep here and talk about very
important and sometimes very painful
subjects my sexuality
my eating disorder
you know my journey just like everyone's
journey everyone has difficulties
and i hope this book helps um
anybody who's
challenged emotionally and
and just you know if you have an eating
disorder hopefully this will help if you
aren't sure of your
um sexuality if you don't as far as your
gender identification or anything
i hope this will help um
people along the way in their journey
so which part of your journey
in having your memory refreshed based on
the research and you going back
were you even surprised by
just having that memory
jogged
billy jeans well the one thing
the one thing that came to mind is how
busy i was as far as trying to play
tennis
and lead
at the same time
own tournaments being a business person
quite frankly i don't know how i did it
looking back
god did give me extra energy
and i think that's the reason i was able
to do it and also i really wanted
things to change i had such a will
to want things to change and i got very
lucky
because there's a few players around me
and or i'm around them
to want to change things the original
line in 1970 is a huge story it's in
here
um you know there was nine of us willing
to give up our careers for the future
generations
and um there were three things that we
really cared about and that was that any
girl born in the world
if she was good enough would have a
place to compete
uh number two that
um
that should be appreciated for
accomplishment
not only her looks like everything and
when we play when i played against bobby
riggs for instance when i was coming out
when they were in the egyptian litter
they're bringing me out 90 million
people are watching howard cassell only
talked about my looks never talked once
about my accomplishments so that was the
number two and then number three was be
able to make a living playing test
because as amateurs before 1968 we made
fourteen dollars a day we never wanted
that to happen again for women and we've
been getting uh shut out a lot by the
guys i wanted us to be together
they did not want us so that was a tough
time it was really a tough time
and uh and then because of that moment
where the original line signed a one
dollar contract with gladys hellman and
she went out and got sponsorship we got
people to run tournaments for us but
every time a young person or a player
today gets a
a check a woman player
you can go right back to that moment
when we did that because uh that's the
reason they're making so much money um
so it's still relevant today because
history is relevant today and many times
and i think it's really important for
young people uh to know a lot about
history because it does help them to
shape the future
i know it helped me when i was young and
trying to help shape the future billie
jean king all in an autobiography where
all books are sold right here on the
rich eisen show so now the conversation
around somebody like naomi osaka
uh is about mental
health and mental awareness she just had
an interview
a press conference via zoom in which she
stepped away because uh as her agent
described it
uh the line of questioning was
disturbing
and so now that's the conversation
that's being had right now i'd love to
give you the floor on what you think
about
uh the conversation surrounding osaka
obviously what
uh occurred with simone biles during the
olympics plays into that
uh i'd love to give you the floor billie
jean king and tell us what you think
about this subject matter
i have total empathy for them i want
them to be okay i want them to take care
of themselves
i think we need to do a better job when
they're young
as to what it means to be a high profile
or a professional athlete like an
olympian or a pro tennis player
because part of being a pro and part of
why we make all this money
is because we have spent time with the
media and the media are very important
because they tell our story now i
realized in the old days that's all we
had and thank god the traditional media
stepped up for women's tennis or we
wouldn't have what we have today but
today with social media we have both but
part of being a professional athlete
i think is talking to the media
and the most important thing we can do
is not take things personally
i i can tell you what i used to think
about when i did media conferences every
time i'd walk in basically it was all
men
and then i'd ask i'd ask them questions
before we'd start sometimes like what is
like what does feminists mean to you we
go around we started laughing we had a
great time
um
but the important thing is i would look
at each person that
this guy
or woman later
is trying to make a living just like we
are
and so i i'm always big on trying to
look at the other person uh and what
what they're dealing with
and we're kind of in this together
because we help each other
so i kind of look at this as a team even
though sometimes they're going to be
horrible to us and the way they ask
questions
and
i can tell you the other guys or other
people who are doing media when a when a
a guy asks the question inappropriately
they are not happy with them as one of
their peers so i don't i don't know if
people think about that but i i know
that they get upset sometimes with their
peers for saying how could you ask such
a stupid question you know we're trying
to trying to get answers here we're not
going to get any answers this way which
was kind of funny to watch and then
um
i just think part of being a great
athlete and part of being
um and way with the reason we get all
this money is because we've had the
media all these years they've promoted
us and so people can know us
because that's the way people like it
it's not we hit a good forehand or a
backhand it's that you like the player
you don't like the player
they're great this way you don't like
this part about them but how does that
happen it's through exposure it's
through people talking about us and
we're and so i think it's we've got to
find a way
i'm not saying that the press
conferences can't maybe be changed a
little i don't know i think it's good to
always keep improving things but i think
we also need to do much better job when
they when the athletes are young
uh that we have a proper rookie school
uh and and get them ready for what it
really means to be
a top athlete and part of that deal and
part of that deal
is you've got to talk to people you just
if you don't want to fine don't but um
i don't think that helps the sport i'm
very big on talking to people because i
i know with us trying to change
tennis trying to change women's sports
if we hadn't had the media we wouldn't
have what we have today
well and the issue with social media
billie jean king is it is a two-way
street that yes you can use it as a
platform to get your story out right you
can do that
and the issue is is the other way around
and the stuff that osaka and or biles
must see in the palm of their hand
immediately responses to
to if they look at it i would counsel
them not to because that might actually
help
you know or helps the wrong word that
might actually lead to the potential
conflating
of what somebody is saying by hitting
send on the phone
and and saying that that might be the
same intention of a member of the
traditional media asking a question
and i'm just wondering like what what do
you what do you what
i'm i'll go ahead i guess no no no no i
just totally agree with you okay i'll
tell you why when i when i was 15
my dad
because i was yanking around about some
you know the way they wrote about me in
the paper in long beach california was
born and raised and i just lost the
match and why didn't they put me on the
front page when i win you know one
tournament and i'm going on and on he
said just stop
you know he said when did this happen i
said yesterday says exactly
yesterday he said stop
he says i don't want you to read any
clippings i don't want you to look at
any video
me i don't want you to look at anything
anymore that was the greatest best
best thing he could have ever done for
me and that's basically what you're
saying
don't read it don't look at it because
you're always going to get people who
love to hear themselves talk you're
always going to get
people who are negative
they thrive on social media and that's
where you got to ignore them you just
have to ignore them now i i just don't
think it's important i just don't think
you should be looking at yourself that
much i i don't think um and the big
scheme of life
seriously we're athletes uh but i do
think we have a platform and a
responsibility to help make this world a
better place so
i i feel for the athletes because i know
some really suffer
um so i think
gotta figure this out but i agree with
you did not look at the negative
feedback from
from social media just ignore that
there's they're bullies a lot of people
no doubt they thrive on it that's the
downside the good side is so you can get
your word out you you have a platform so
there's always going to be the good and
the bad part of that so you got to be
selected i'm just wondering what the
notifications at billie jean king would
have looked like after you kicked bobby
riggs's ass billie jean you know what oh
my god can you imagine can you imagine
how many people i'd have
it would have been great i would love to
i'd love i'd love to be a young athlete
today are you kidding really you have a
platform you make money
you can make do good with that money you
can give it back you can help
underserved people you oh my gosh i just
think of the opportunities
and the leadership opportunities they
have because they have this platform and
just think of all the different ways
athletes can help make the world a
better place and we can do that that's
our job i think that's part of being
blessed being a professional athlete or
one of the top olympic athletes i mean i
watched the olympics it was so thrilling
so uh in in i guess wrapping up our
conversation billie jean king what's
next what do you think should be next
for what you um started
uh when you
from from the from the point of view
obviously you've got your billie jean
king initiative
but in terms of the cause for the female
athlete what what do you think is next
here in 2021
a lot of my partner are very involved we
really want to we want soccer to get
more
we want women's hockey ice hockey to
have a league eventually uh with the top
players they do have a league that's
very good but we need the top players
that they're the ones that drive
everything
we are so young women's force is so late
in the marketplace we're in our infancy
so we have a long way to go
we also do an initiative we're very big
you know on de ni and you know uh
diversity equity and inclusion we help
companies do that uh we try to give make
money and give it back pretty quickly
sometimes like with the front line
workers particularly women of color
um i'm involved in
investing in the first women's bank
in chicago fidelity and and bank of
america involved with that too
so we're just going to start that i'm
very big on girls following the money
just like boys are taught um make a lot
of money and and then give it give it
out to people
who need it they're underserved and
create opportunities and training
but as far as women's tennis and men's
tennis i would like to see us together
more i know the wta and the uh atp are
working together and then you have a
third group who started with djokovic
we've got to figure out how to get
together
uh tennis has
immense opportunities we don't have
enough social media content so we need
to really punch that up we can make a
lot more money have better revenue
streams
so tennis in as far as women's tennis we
are definitely the leader in women's
sports without any question but we want
i just want all women's sports to do
well because women's sports you know 94
of them
in c-suites and businesses identify with
being athletes
it helps us to negotiate it helps us to
be resilient all the things it teaches
boys it teaches girls so i really want
girls and boys to be in sports you don't
have to be the best but you learn about
business you learn how to navigate uh
the
the world that we live in uh when you
learn all these things through sports
and also
relationships you build up relationships
and relationships are everything
before i let you go billie jean king i
got to just revisit one thing you said
in the conversation about howard cosell
during your match with bobby riggs was
commenting only on your looks did you
ever have an opportunity to address that
subject with howard afterwards no i
didn't well i never saw it i didn't see
the um i didn't actually see the match
no i didn't watch the match until 25 or
30 years later when i had to actually
i had to watch the match for the book
and comment on the match and
i could not believe it when i started to
watch i thought okay great howard cosell
the best announcer he was like number
one
uh and big influencer and he was tight
with ali they helped each other become
famous
more than ever
um and i thought i used to be very
envious of of
of them in a way that i didn't have a
broadcaster that was
helping my profile you know increased uh
i thought god would just always
on the outside looking in but
no i i didn't when i saw it i could not
believe it that howard went on and on
about my look go take your glasses off
do this she could be in hollywood
another i'm like waiting for the
and she won this through that or she was
in the hall of fame and then when bobby
came out bobby came out right after me
and all they talked about was his
accomplishments and it was so i just
could not believe that's what was said
in 1973 with the with the match and
of course it was just after title nine
was passed in 72. so i was like
on that just shows you how the times
were it just it's indicative
of the culture at the time
wow
that was one of your observations having
never seen it watched it back just for
your i couldn't believe it i was in
shock i didn't think he would do that i
thought he'd at least say oh she won a
wimbledon or two or she won the us open
or
well something not you i know i like
howard i got along well with them well
look billie jean king i'm no howard
cosell and um but you always have a
place here with anything that i do i
don't know if i'm kind of going to get a
little emotional telling you this
because my my mother reveres you to this
day she's
she's uh 83 she doesn't like me saying
her age but you mentioned yours but um
she reveres you and revered you and
growing up
as i did you know uh hearing your name
she loves telling the story about me as
a kid
um having a friend down the street named
karen and she and i would play and we
would fight about who got to be you
instead of bobby riggs
and
that's a fact that's how i grew up so
you always have a place wow it's how you
always have a place here billie jean
king whenever you want with whatever
you're doing please
well i appreciate that richard say hi to
your mom what's her name aveline eisen
that's her name evelyn say hi to her
tell her keep going for it she she sure
still is billie jean king congrats on
the book um can't wait for everybody to
get it and uh let's let's keep talking
down the line all right thanks a lot
rich i really appreciate it you bet all
in in autobiography the author billie
jean king you can follow her at billie
jean king on twitter and instagram right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here